so there's a lot of people who have been
talking increasingly about dual
nationale
text since 1976 Canada has affirmatively
allowed dual or multiple nationality not
just to but you can have three or four
etc other countries in the world have
also made similar moves and a lot of
countries that have more developing
economies have changed their laws in the
last 20 to 30 years to allow dual
citizenship or multiple citizenship in
part because they want to make sure that
their citizens who are now living in
other countries remain tied to their
lands of origin sometimes for social
reasons often for economic reasons they
would like those people to help
participate in the development of the
economies that they left behind people
often worry about dual citizenship that
that that participation say in the
homeland society might detract from
their participation in the country
they're living that they're way too
focused on where they came from social
science research including my own
research shows that people who are
engaged in politics in the homeland or
in issues things like human rights
violations etc in the land that they
came from actually tend to be the people
who participate even more in the
politics and the civic issues of the
place they live in and what's
interesting is things like political
skills and the sense of community and
the sense of involvement and wanting to
give back is actually something that
learns and gets layered on top of each
other